hey I was going for us my name is today
I'm very excited because we're playing
the power drill massacre if you don't
know anything about this game it's
basically by the same creator who did a
babysitter bloodbath which is one of my
favorite videos because the game this is
so [ __ ] amazing the retro is [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
it is a demo though don't know how long
I'll get to play oh my god it looks
amazing
power drill massacre you feel the
tension
now my god let's get into this [ __ ] I've
been waiting so patiently for him to
release another game oh my god I'm so
excited about what is this
okay
I had the trunk sorry I forgot the trunk
is the bank my first night pick it up
yeah Megan you look hot as [ __ ] look at
that face oh my god look at that face
you look like my next mistake loves a
game wanna play
oh god Jeff you look pretty [ __ ] up
don't you go in there sweetie oh my god
yes [ __ ] yes oh my god what is that
sound all right so where are we going I
guess we're going this way
beauty
like even though the graphics are like
Silent Hill style oh my gosh I'm very
tired do it your way to make it yeah I
don't know
every mine's my salad hair like I like
it it's a great [ __ ] game great
atmosphere just like this one so I got
to give him props for that I felt like I
didn't get I didn't give him props in
the last episode I felt all bad because
I honestly really appreciate games like
these who would put a house had a
[ __ ] place like this where the hell
am I going this road is awful
ok we can go up here yes I love Jeff
chases Christ
oh [ __ ] that's a nice house there's
someone up there
oh it's been a terrible accident it says
police get annoying cuz it's annoying me
sir
sure wait no where the hell did he go
what the [ __ ] still better for graphics
in Minecraft I'm doing this open go
inside what a creepy building oh my god
my my shirt is basically the clouds from
Toy Story that's [ __ ] awesome Oh got
it
someone locked the door this building
looked a lot nicer on the outside I
gotta say oh my god dude this is so
Silent Hill that grungy feel man what
happened to this place
yes you got a key with red paint so red
paint
maybe there's a red door somewhere not
here something looks like an article
ripped out of newspaper reading the
search continues for the two missing
campus in the Pocono Mountains made
cincy sergeant and lori summers of Long
Island New York have been missing since
June 8th the campsite belongings have
been located by the Vince theatres have
few leads police say there are no
visible signs of struggle and this
continues to be a rescue mission
the race is missing five years ago so
some campers disappeared five years ago
oh god what is that oh my god what is
going on that's actually creepy stop it
the [ __ ] is going on here oh my god
some kind of machine some kind of
machine some guided machine [ __ ]
machines man it's a big drill guess this
was factory now I would place a [ __ ]
factory on top of a goddamn Mountain
you best be insane this place has got a
maze oh my god like the first game Jesus
Christ it was so hard to orient in okay
why does it say here sugar tunnel well I
love I love me some sugar baby oh my god
what is this [ __ ] another [ __ ] maze
that's amazing
where the hell am i oh God
no gunshots but thank you Jesus Christ
man you can't just come at me out of
[ __ ] where's my mouse you can't just
come at me out of nowhere
[ __ ] hell well I never saved so I'll
have to replay everything again
now I remember a lot of things about the
other game let's get this guy I will
[ __ ] you Jeff get a dick for all I care
basically the first game was almost
impossible to finish I remember now it
took me so many [ __ ] drives
oh my god cuz he won't let you [ __ ]
save in this game alright alright
alright okay you lock the door you [ __ ]
good job you did it we should [ __ ]
door anyway it's a little nowhere I feel
like I'm being watched here oh my god
you look like my next mistake loves a
game wanna what the [ __ ] was that sound
what does shit-bomb backing up backin up
backin up backin up cuz my daddy taught
me good I'm backin the hell out of here
and I'm like oh my god oh my god and my
god
hi hello it said candy friend huh
something's blinking over here there's a
note up to the corner my name is David
HP my address is blob of lividity I
think I've got it down here I'm hiding
this note and hope somebody will uncover
it and know the truth about what
happened to us somebody came to our
campsite in the middle of the night
it doesn't seem like the note was
finished oh my god it's the people that
got abducted five years ago why are we
walking into this [ __ ] now where is this
[ __ ] dripping coming from I don't
like this please please
does that mean he's near I'm legit
[ __ ] terrified don't scare me like
you did before please I'm keeping the
flashlight off because I don't know if
he sees me they were they oh my god I
need to get out of here man [ __ ] hear
him I heard him I heard him where is he
oh oh I think I peed a little bit why is
he so [ __ ] scary what the [ __ ]
happened here this radioactive [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm böck your name this is very not
good this is really bad for me okay I
got that [ __ ] weird I static again I
don't know what that means but I don't
think I can handle another [ __ ] heart
attack